C'était un soir de fin d'après-midi.
On m'avait donné
un mystérieux rendez-vous,
dans une mystérieuse ruelle,
à une mystérieuse horaire.
Le froid commençait à me mordre.
Et je me posais la question,
était-ce une farce ?
Est-ce que quelqu'un allait
vraiment venir à ma rencontre ?
Je doutais.
Et je les ai vus apparaître.
Deux hommes portant
une mystérieuse caisse.
Le doute m'habitait.
Pourquoi avaient-ils
tous les deux des chapeaux ?
Et surtout comment avaient-ils fait,
pour avoir des chaussures
aussi impeccablement cirées ?
Et la grande question qui se posait :
c'était que contenait
cette mystérieuse caisse ?
- Monsieur Olicard ?
- Oui ?
- C'est pour vous.
- Parce que du coup, vous partez ?
Non, parce que moi,
c'est là-bas en fait.
Mais comme vous, vous étiez deux,
que je suis tout seul...
Non ?
ça a l'air très très lourd.
Je vais chercher des roulettes,
ou un siège.
Cool, les gars.
Monsieur Olicard.
Nous ne nous connaissons pas,
mais je suis votre chaîne
avec beaucoup d'intérêt.
Voyez vous, j'ai une certaine passion
pour les mécanismes cachés du cerveau.
C'est une passion familiale,
c'est justement un illustre ancêtre
qui m'a transmis ce coffret.
Le nom de cette machine
est "cérébro-coder".
Je l'ai étudiée pendant
de nombreuses années,
sans en percer tous les mystères.
Je me permets de
vous faire parvenir cet objet,
qui j'en suis sûr,
ne vous résistera pas.
Alors, c'est pas la peine de mettre
des espoirs, quand même, trop forts.
Toutefois, vous devez
dans un premier temps,
me prouver que
vous en êtes bien digne.
Vous devez trouver
grâce à ma carte postale
et à votre sens
de l'intuition uniquement,
le moyen d'ouvrir le cadenas
que j'ai moi-même ajouté
à la machine
de mon arrière-grand-père.
ça veut dire que c'est
la petite fille de Nikola Tesla.
Bonne chance, Iva.
Iva y arriver, ou Iva galérer.
Okay.
Et on pourrait dire ça,
c'est le premier cercle.
ça ce serait le deuxième cercle.
Et ça m'avance à quoi ?
Pas à grand chose, c'est sûr.
Est-ce que la lumière me permettrait
de voir quelque chose de travers ?
Genre un repère pour les chiffres.
Est-ce que j'ai un endroit,
où j'aurais une suite de symboles ?
Qui me dirait :
Fabou, suis plutôt l'ordre des symboles.
Grâce à ma carte postale
et à votre sens de l'intuition.
De l'intuition !
Pas de la déduction.
Donc il faut que j'y aille à l'intuition.
J'ai envie de croire qu'il y a un indice
quelque part, qui me permette de...
Une clé qui me permette
de comprendre cette carte postale.
Ce que je me dis,
même si je prends juste les chiffres
qui sont reliés par le symbole de l'infini,
en admettant que le reste ce soit
de la déco pour me brain un peu.
J'y crois pas une seconde.
Je vais l'essayer
parce qu'il va falloir avancer.
Comme ça, je vais me libérer
au moins de cette hypothèse là.
Je vais essayer ça,
dans cet ordre là.
Sept, huit, trois, quatre.
Trois, quatre, sept, huit.
Donc ça c'est le code,
trois, quatre, sept, huit.
Ce qui nous permet
d'ouvrir le cadenas.
Je sais pas tant pourquoi.
On a fait extérieur,
premier cercle.
Premier cercle, extérieur.
On l'a fait, en fait il y a que ça
qui compte, c'est qu'on l'ai fait.
Toute manière,
la carte postale me disait :
"Votre sens de l'intuition".
J'ai de l'intuition d'essayer ça.
Donc là c'est l'ouverture,
c'est ça, ça s'ouvre ?
Okay, putain, chan-mé.
Ah c'est lourd, la vache !
Oh !
C'est stylé !
ça tient ça ?
C'est incroyable.
Bravo !
Vous avez percé mon code à jour.
Félicitations.
Voilà ce que je sais :
Mon ancêtre travaillait sur
une mesure des ondes électriques
émises par le cerveau au moment
de la construction de cette machine.
Et c'est à peu près tout.
Même si elle est revenue
dans ma famille depuis un moment,
je n'ai jamais réussi
à la faire fonctionner.
C'est pour ça
que j'ai pensé à vous.
Il paraît que de nombreux génies
s'y sont essayés au fil du temps,
alors pourquoi pas vous ?
Iva.
Iva continuer de galérer.
PS : Il paraît qu'il y a un manuel,
mais je n'ai jamais réussi à le trouver.
Un point de départ pour vous ?
Putain, je sais pas
par où commencer.
On va tout regarder,
on va tout détailler.
Ici, on a des petits boutons qui
nous permettent d'aller sur des choses.
Au centre, ça a l'air de pouvoir se lever,
mais c'est bloqué.
Ici, un bouton affichage.
Okay, j'aurai peut-être une combinaison
à faire pour le lancer, lui.
Là, on a clairement trois petits cadenas
qui nous permettent d'ouvrir.
Là, je pense que c'est pas un hasard
qu'on puisse enlever ça.
Okay.
Exploration !
Là on a plein de commandes
de plein de trucs
qui font réagir
le mini cinématographe.
Ah, antenne !
Mais c'est l'antenne... Ou pas.
Peut-être.
Ecoute, on va le mettre là pour l'instant,
si jamais c'est toi.
Un bouton de décompte, okay.
Une plaque qu'on peut
mettre autrement que ça.
D'accord, on peut faire
correspondre Pi,
on peut faire correspondre
d'autres trucs, okay.
D'accord, donc il faut se mettre
en quête du manuel, clairement.
Là, il y avait la petite serrure,
si je mets ça dedans.
ça ne rentre pas.
Okay !
Je vais quand même
continuer à regarder.
Je suis vraiment très con.
J'allais dire :
Hey, ça ça va
très bien là dedans !
Et après, je peux refermer.
Et en plus, après je peux remettre
le cadenas et ça c'est...
Bah c'est pas ouf.
J'ai pas trop regardé la base.
Ateliers Tesla construction
& Electronique, Labsterium,
produit conçu en un seul et unique
exemplaire pour monsieur Fabien Olicard.
Tout à fait.
J'ai pas l'impression que ces deux figures
m'emmènent sur quelque chose.
Je me dis quand même peut-être, ici.
Donc là, il y a ça.
ça, je l'ai ici.
C'était son sens initial.
Il me dit, lève ça,
occupe toi de ça.
En bas, il y a un mécanisme.
Inversion, modulation,
différenciation, variation !
Ils aiment bien les mots en 'ion',
chez Tesla.
Là, je vois le grand H que je retrouve là,
par contre mon bouton...
Ah, ce serait quel symbole ?
Aux angles de lui,
correspondent quand il est bien mis.
J'ai bientôt fait un cercle complet.
On aurait bien aimé que ce soit ça.
Je me dis quand même bêtement,
j'ai pas cherché à voir s'il n'y a pas
une trappe secrète, ou quelque chose.
Parce que les constructions en bois
comme ça avec plein de croisés,
ça me fait toujours penser
qu'il y a quelque chose
que tu peux tirer ou pousser,
qui s'ouvrirait derrière.
Très lâche mais...
Oh !
Je suis content parce qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose.
Mais rien de spécial pour le moment.
Et en plus, ça n'a servi,
pour l'instant à rien.
C'est à la fois jouissif et frustrant,
quand tu as quelque chose qui bouge.
Parce que tu as l'impression
d'avoir avancé,  en fait c'est comme "Lost".
Tu viens d'ouvrir une porte,
mais t'as pas refermé celle d'avant.
Et après, t'as ce vieux truc
de biais cognitif,
où tu veux essayer de bouger
tous les trucs qui ressemblent à ça,
en te disant :
Si ça se trouve
il y en a un deuxième.
Il n'y a rien dedans.
Oh my god !
Regardez, en fait je me suis dit,
mais putain, il bouge
quand même pas mal.
En fait, ça s'ouvre !
ça s'ouvre complètement et peut-être,
ai-je trouvé le journal ?
Ah ! Non je déconne.
Il n'y avait rien dedans.
Là on a fait une avancée.
Iva, j'ai trouvé le carnet
dont tu me parlais.
Trop de choses d'un coup là.
Un crayon.
Un crayon qui ne crayonne pas.
Quand on ouvre,
au lieu d'avoir de l'encre,
il y a quelque chose
qui est un aimant !
ça c'est intéressant.
ça veut dire que
j'ai chopé un aimant.
Là j'ai chopé un truc de formule.
Et là, des notes diverses et variées.
Okay, Mendelev Dimitri.
Le cérébro-codeur 3000 est l'une
des œuvres majeures de ma vie.
Vous qui lisez ce manuel,
vous devez faire partie
des esprits les plus géniaux.
Flattez-moi !
J'ai mis au point une méthode
pour analyser les schémas de pensée
des cerveaux les plus brillants,
et pour les garder
dans la mémoire de la machine.
Ah !
Elle peut ainsi accumuler
les connaissances
de ceux qui sauront
résoudre ses tests.
Mieux, elle peut les imprimer
sous forme d'un cachet
orodispersible facilement
assimilable.
Il n'y a qu'un seul problème :
Je n'ai pas réussi à optimiser
la lecture et l'écriture en simultané.
C'est-à-dire que la pilule sert aussi
de mémoire à la machine.
Je ne peux pas faire de copies.
La dernière pilule contiendra
donc les connaissances
de tous ceux qui ont
bien voulu l'y laisser.
Okay, là on a du schéma,
là on a du plan !
Là, on a de la rigolade !
Ah bah super !
Aller, quelqu'un a arraché des pages,
comme par hasard.
Alors, j'ai de quoi
initialiser la machine là !
ça, je le mets à zéro.
Interrupteur en bas,
interrupteur en bas.
Bonjour, me dit
le cérébro-coder 3000.
Et ben bien le bonjour.
ça fait plaisir.
Ben c'est résolu.
ça faisait beaucoup d'attente
pour un casse tête qui dit bonjour,
c'est une fin de vidéo.
Okay, bonjour,
j'ai atténuation qui s'est allumé
et qui s'éteint quand
j'enlève cette plaque.
Oh c'est drôle ça.
Ou alors qui s'est éteint par hasard,
non il s'est pas éteint par hasard.
On l'a initialisé.
On va chercher la prochaine étape.
Et la prochaine étape,
forcément le manuel,
quelqu'un a arraché les pages.
Bravo Nikoko.
Est-ce que ça,
ça peut m'aider ?
Est-ce qu'on a
ne serait-ce qu'une base de N ?
Non.
Là, j'ai les symboles.
Là, j'ai tous les symboles.
Qu'on retrouve là, ouais.
Okay, donc cette page doit m'aider
pour cette hauteur là, je pense.
Est-ce que ça ne serait pas
la troisième page ?
Là, j'ai rien oublié là dedans.
Okay, je suis certain d'un truc,
c'est que je n'ai pas compris ça.
C'est la bonne nouvelle !
Est-ce que ces choses là
viennent naturellement ?
On a même pas essayé, Fabien.
T'imagines si les trois cadenas
ne servaient à rien,
et qu'en fait,
juste ça se levait.
Ce serait tellement drôle.
Ah oui, il y a deux charnières,
donc ça va se lever comme ça.
J'aimerais inverser
la modulation du filtre de latence
pour faire une variation sur
la différenciation, vous comprenez ?
Je crois que c'est ma fréquence radio
qui n'est pas bonne.
C'est facile de faire
le mec qui s'y connait.
Bleu, vert, rouge.
Bleu.
On tente des choses.
Je suis passé à côté
de quelque chose depuis le départ.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Si je me mets déjà à chanter,
on n'a pas fini de le faire.
Peut-être qu'il fallait
savoir parler Russe.
Est-ce que je perds
mon temps là dessus ?
Je crois pas.
Est-ce que ça pourrait servir
peut-être de coordonnée ?
Un, deux, trois, quatre,
cinq, six, sept, huit.
Là on a huit lettres.
Les huit lettres,
est-ce que je les retrouve là ?
Là, il y en a huit aussi.
Donc là, j'ai le N inversé.
Donc là, j'ai toutes les lettres.
Donc là, c'est pas un hasard.
Qu'est-ce que je peux en faire de ça ?
Est-ce que je peux faire fusionner...
La première lettre c'est L.
Et L est okay.
Est-ce qu'après,
je me mets sur un.
Pour dire ça, c'est ça.
Elle passe là.
Et ça reste allumé.
Donc après, je vais sur deux
et je passe sur Pi.
Et ça s'allume.
C'est pas mal ça.
Je sais pas si ça s'allumait
tout à l'heure.
Attends, je vais au bout de mon idée.
Y...
Et ça s'allume.
Quatre, c'est ça
avec la bulle en dessous.
ça s'allume.
Cinq, le O.
Le B.
ça s'allume.
Sept, le N à l'envers.
Putain !
C'est incroyable.
C'est incroyable à vivre !
Il en avait du matos, Tesla.
Putain, c'est jusqu'au-boutiste.
Donc là, il y a ça.
Mais c'est...
Je n'arrive même pas à comprendre
et je veux pas comprendre
comment Tesla a pu faire ça.
Là, on a un truc avec
un petit papier stylé dedans.
Une montre à gousset cassée.
Ce qui veut dire qu'elle donne
deux fois par jour la bonne heure.
Une boîte avec des billes.
Des binocles à ma vue, incroyable.
Une feuille,
on va voir après ce que c'est.
La photo d'un magicien, on dirait.
Trois années de physique
en un volume.
Et du coup, une boîte stylée.
ça fait trop d'éléments à chaque fois !
Je vous ai dit c'est Lost ce truc.
Et ça, si je le mets dans mes oreilles,
est-ce que déjà quelque chose tourne ?
C'est Wejdene, c'est incroyable.
Elle m'a dit, tu prends tes caleçons
sales et tu hors de ma vue.
Casque cérébrale
à conduction osseuse.
C'est comment
on les met justement.
Ah, c'est à conduction osseuse.
Oui, je viens comprendre en fait,
ça te fait vibrer l'os.
Et c'est comme ça que tu entends
le son à l'intérieur de ta tête en fait.
Donc ça, à un moment donné,
j'imagine que peut-être,
ça m'enverra quelque chose.
Et là, cette pince ?
C'est marqué dessus : Pigeon.
Ah c'est un truc de pigeon voyageur,
d'accord okay.
Qu'est-ce qu'il me dit ?
Fréquence radio : NI.KO.LA.
Est-ce que ça me donnerait
des fréquences avec ça ?
C'est quoi, c'est du nitrate ?
Je pense que là c'est un calcul à faire
pour trouver la fréquence radio finale.
Et ils me disent que de toute manière,
on a pas l'antenne donc...
Putain, moi depuis le départ,
je suis hypé par ce truc.
Et qu'est-ce que
j'ai pas exploré encore ?
Bah le bouquin de physique.
Bon j'ai pas regardé sous la boîte,
mais je pense pas qu'il y ait de chose.
Qu'est-ce que... Bonjour !
C'est pour ça que vous m'aviez dit
que ce serait long à faire,
le temps que je lise tout ça.
Je comprends, je comprends.
Il est fou ce livre en vrai.
Est-ce que si je fais tout doucement,
il y a quelque chose qui tombe ?
Il y a pas un sommaire ?
Quelque chose de caché.
Je suis la colombe,
la jolie colombe.
N,I.
Les points entre les lettres
ne sont pas hasardeuses.
Ah si je l'ai là, NI59.
LA 180.
Bon je vais essayer de les additionner
pour mettre la fréquence radio.
NI ensemble, ça fait 59.
On va dire 60.
K, 39 mais on va dire 40,
ça fait 100 moins deux, 98.
Le O, ça fait 16 donc
ça fait 116 moins deux, 114.
114.
Et là, je l'ai vu.
Putain, ils me sont tous
sautés aux yeux.
Ah oui, c'est un point d'interrogation, LA.
Est-ce qu'il y a un autre LA,
sans point d'interrogation ?
J'ai pas l'impression.
280 + 14 = 294.
294.
Ah, il y a antenne manquante.
Imaginons que ce soit
l'antenne qui manque.
Du coup la théorie
n'est pas mauvaise.
La théorie n'est pas si bête, je trouve.
Parce que ça, si c'est si c'était l'antenne,
ce serait bizarre.
En même temps,
c'est stylé et ça tient debout.
Il faut l'antenne, de toute manière,
l'affichage est très clair à ce sujet.
Dans l'électrique,
dans électricité qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
Etude de gaz, électricité.
Phénomènes fondamentaux,
pile électrique,
galvanomètre, électroaimant...
Regardons quand même dans électricité
voir si je retrouve ce schéma là.
Je regarde dans les formules,
les trucs comme ça.
Bon bah dommage.
Est-ce que je fais pas
comme le coup d'avant,
je suis pas en train
de me fourvoyer ?
Est-ce que j'ai écouté au moins,
depuis que j'ai mis la fréquence ?
Non mais c'est bête.
Non mais de toute manière,
il y aurait pas marqué antenne manquante.
Tant qu'il y aura marqué antenne
manquante, je peux rien écouter.
Donc il faut que
je cherche l'antenne, en fait.
C'est ça, il faut encore que j'oublie ce...
Je pense qu'en fait,
je me casse la tête parce que lui
est directement accessible.
Mais qu'en fait,
il me manque l'antenne.
Peut-être que l'antenne est cachée
là dedans et qu'il faut que je trouve ça.
Mais j'ai l'impression
qu'à chaque fois,
je reviens là dessus,
à chaque fois c'est une connerie.
Du coup, sur quoi je peux partir,
qui ferait que je n'ai pas encore l'antenne ?
Tu te dis, est-ce que ça,
ça s'enlevait pas,
et au fond il y avait une antenne.
Bonjour, on m'appelle
ni clous ni vis.
Ma spécialité ?
Vérifier si les clous
et les vis bougent.
Ma conclusion est formelle, non.
D'ailleurs, je pourrais même
plutôt que de faire ça,
le tester directement pour voir
s'il y en a un qui vient.
On avait fait une boîte un jour
comme ça, la pandora box.
Où il y a un truc qui était venu
comme ça directement avec un aimant.
Je refais les mêmes, parce que
comme je n'ai pas d'autre idée.
Mais c'était bien
de le faire en boucle.
Je pense que je suis passé
à côté de quelque chose.
Donc je vais revenir
à ce qu'on appelle les basiques,
c'est à dire, est-ce que
tu as une idée Loïc ?
- Phase d'exploration !
- Exactement,
je vais me refaire l'ensemble de la boîte
et de ce que j'ai sorti, etc.
Pour essayer de voir
si j'ai pas zappé quelque chose.
Et je l'ai pas fait à l'aimant.
J'ai fait le docteur à l'aimant,
mais pas complètement.
Donc je fais le docteur.
J'espère juste ne pas...
Oh putain.
Mais c'est fou ou pas ?
C'est incroyable.
Mais attends, mais je continue.
Putain, je suis grave.
J'ai adoré ce moment,
je l'ai détesté tout autant.
En fait, quand lui était enclenché,
il bougeait pas du tout.
Il n'a pas du tout jeu.
Et là vraiment, je passais
par acquis de conscience partout.
Est-ce que ça, je peux le chopper
et que ce serait ça l'antenne ?
Non, ça vient pas ça.
Elle est où mon autre barrette là ?
Non, ça fait rien.
Ah là, j'ai fait tomber un truc.
Alors moi, j'ai peur
de faire des conneries.
Oh mais il se passe des choses ici,
mon gars.
Mais tout se déboite en fait.
En fait c'est une boîte IKEA.
Rien à voir avec Nikola Tesla.
Mais comment on peut passer de :
Je galère depuis une heure et demie à,
hey tout se démonte en fait.
Donc j'ai passé l'aimant là,
par acquis de conscience
en fait partout,
et ici c'est venu.
De là, je me suis dit, le petit aimant,
merde il s'est enfoncé et tout.
J'ai même eu peur
d'avoir fait une connerie,
du coup j'ai appuyé
jusqu'au bout dessus.
Et il y a ça qui est tombé
de l'autre côté.
Et du coup à l'intérieur,
il y avait ça.
Et ça par contre,
peut-être c'est l'antenne.
Attends.
Je vais mettre ça
sur les oreilles au cas où.
Enfin sur les oreilles...
Parce que s'il y a un son qui vient,
je veux l'entendre.
ça se visse.
Ici, ça doit être ça l'antenne, c'est sûr.
J'ai trouvé l'antenne mon gars.
Oui !
- Onde cérébral illisible,
merci de recalibrer.
Premier protocole, X1Z1.
- X1Z1.
- Deuxième protocole, X5Y5.
Troisième protocole, X4Z6.
Quatrième protocole, Y5Z1.
- ça doit être ça.
Premier protocole, X1Z1.
Alors si ça c'est sept zéro.
Y zéro et X zéro.
Et que ça c'est X7.
ça veut dire quoi ?
Un, deux, trois, quatre,
cinq, six, sept.
C'est dans ce sens-là quoi.
Donc X1 ce serait lui.
J'ai dit X1Z1.
- Premier protocole, X1Z1.
- X1, donc X1.
X, ce serait dans ce sens là du coup.
Et Z, ce serait dans ce sens-là.
Y5Z1, donc 0Y5,
zéro, un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq.
Z1 ça, donc c'est lui.
c'est pas ça,
putain c'est pas ça.
Si c'est ça !
Oh putain !
Je me suis saoulé, comme un âne
qui aurait bu du vin du coup.
La vache, je me suis soulax.
Je sais pas, vous avez dû rire
dans les commentaires.
Mais j'ai eu un bug sur comment
on traduit les coordonnées de ça
et comment on fait
les croisements.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Je n'ai jamais fait de trucs
en alvéolaire comme ça.
Ah ça m'a gavé autant que
je suis content de découvrir une petite clé !
Et là, il y a un petit trou de serrure.
J'espère que ça va là et non pas
dans l'un des trois cadenas,
ce qui m'avancerait pas
à grand chose.
Oui !
Oui, ça s'ouvre !
Wouah, c'est fou, incroyable.
Très joli.
C'est très très beau.
Okay, on vient de découvrir
quand même un endroit
qui est très très très agréable.
Et on vient enfin de se libérer de ça là,
qui me prenait la tête.
Cette clé là,
nous a permis d'ouvrir ça.
On a une autre étiquette derrière.
La clé est de penser autrement.
Cool, cool !
Okay, et est-ce que
cette clé va ailleurs ?
ça, c'est pas exclu.
Ce qui a l'air d'être le cas là,
attends, ça tourne le truc.
ça tourne pour rien ça.
C'est marrant, ce truc là,
ça fait un peu ouvre boulon, un peu.
Ah ça fait complètement
ouvre boulon.
Ah mais j'ai envie
de les dévisser de ouf là.
ça ouvre...
Est-ce que j'ai le droit
de faire ça ?
Au lieu de se faire chier
à trouver trois clés,
il faut peut-être juste
dévisser trois fois.
Après en général,
quand ça marche aussi bien,
c'est que c'est pas un hasard.
Après si c'est ça,
au moins, j'ai compris direct.
Et ça fait du bien aussi dans
un casse-tête comme ça, de se dire:
Okay, une étape longue
et puis une étape un peu plus smooth.
Après on avait l'indice
de penser autrement,
où je me suis dit :
Okay, la clé c'est pas une clé.
C'est pas qu'une clé.
Oh putain !
C'est le plus gros
foutage de gueule du monde !
Oh mon dieu !
Ah c'est trop bien,
mais c'est si joli !
C'est incroyable !
Là je crois que c'est les pages
qui sont déchirées ça.
Configurer, ah putain,
j'avais pas vu le changement.
"Configuration mémorisée.
Veuillez retirer le casque et procéder
à une augmentation du rythme cardiaque,
afin que le test s'effectue dans
les meilleures conditions de lisibilité.
Analyse en cours,
veuillez ne pas retirer votre doigt".
Cardio captation !
Cardio captation.
Fréquence trop faible,
veuillez augmenter votre rythme
cardiaque et réitérer le test.
Pour vrai ?
"Fréquence cardiaque augmentée,
mais pas encore suffisante, du nerf !"
Oh putain, les enfoirés.
J'ai changé de technique.
C'est vraiment le pire
casse-tête du monde !
C'est un casse-tête qui arrive
à se foutre de ta gueule.
Un objet inanimé qui arrive
à se foutre de toi, tu te rends compte ?
Je suis à 150 là, au moins.
"Fin du test cardiaque".
Réactivité, étape 1 sur 1.
J'aurais toujours le doute de,
est-ce qu'il suffisait pas juste
de poser son doigt trois fois ?
Parce que si t'es obligé
de courir comme ça,
J'ai un doute,
mais je me dis que Tesla
se foutrait pas de ma gueule
comme ça quand même.
Réactivité.
Ce test commence avec la vérification
du temps de réaction du cerveau.
La molette de latence
doit être lâchée au bon moment.
Et après, il dit:
"Quelle la frustration
ces problèmes d'affichage".
En plus, le bouton info contact
il n'y a pas d'autre choix que de le marteler.
Est-ce que c'est ça
qu'il faut marteler ?
C'est pas mal là !
Réactivité, étape un sur deux.
Ah ouais, c'est ça le faux contact,
peut-être.
Ah c'est ça, okay !
Si j'appuie pas, ça clignote.
On est passé dans un autre mode.
Okay, réactivité un sur trois.
Aller, là c'est tout petit.
Je sais pas si vous voyez bien, en fait,
si je lâche, l'affichage fait ça.
Okay, on est parti !
Oh, là il est bien là !
Putain, c'est de plus en plus étroit !
Plus en plus étroit,
oui ça marche.
On est bon.
Putain, encore ?!
Oh, je l'ai eu !
One shot.
Etape 2.
Je vais garder le casque, parce que là
il y a le casque qui est réapparu.
Etape 2, MCT one.
MCT, mémoire à court terme.
La partie suivante concerne
la mémoire à court terme.
Notez bien.
Si des leds rouges brillent,
appuyez sur autant de boutons bleus.
Le bleu s'allumait là, ah oui.
Donc s'il y a du bleu,
j'appuie sur du vert.
Puis relâcher, okay.
Etape 2.
Ah okay, stylé !
Donc là j'ai du vert
et du bleu d'allumé.
Donc il faut que j'allume
du rouge et du vert !
J'appuie, je relâche !
Là, il y a du vert et du rouge.
Donc s'il y a du vert et du rouge,
il faut que j'allume du rouge et du bleu.
Rouge et bleu.
Et je relâche.
Ah merde, c'est pas ça.
Est-ce qu'on considère
que c'est un rouge en plus ?
Qu'est-ce que j'ai pas compris ?
Toi t'es allumé, toi t'es allumé,
toi t'es éteint.
Est-ce qu'il y a des trucs...
Mais vous ne m'aurez pas,
car j'ai joué à un jeu de déminage
avec Loïc sur Twitch.
Et il fallait regarder
d'autres endroits des boîtes.
Donc j'ai deux verts et un rouge.
Donc deux verts,
ça veut dire deux rouges.
Et un bleu.
- Etape 2, terminée.
- Etape 2, terminée !
- Résultats exceptionnels.
- Résultats exceptionnels,
merci beaucoup.
Etape 3, PIC-1.
PIC, possession
des informations complexes.
ça doit être ça.
Petite accélération de fin
est très agréable.
Cette partie consiste
à vérifier la capacité
à suivre des instructions complexes.
Vous allez devoir suivre
un set supplémentaire d'instruction
à chacune
des étapes qui suivent.
PIC-1, même instruction
qu'au test mémoire à court terme.
Vous devez également placer
la molette de décompte sur le chiffre
correspondant aux premiers chiffres
du nombre affiché à l'écran.
Activez l'interrupteur de validation
à la fin de l'étape.
Activez un interrupteur
de validation à la fin de l'étape.
C'est quoi, c'est lui ?
Là, on va aller en trois et on fait
comme au mémoire à court terme.
Une led bleue, c'est un bouton vert,
en temps normal, j'ai rien d'autre.
Un bouton vert et ensuite
à la fin de l'étape, je valide.
Okay, c'est bon.
Ensuite cinq, je suis à PIC-2.
PIC-2, même instruction
que l'étape précédente,
si vous devez appuyer
sur au moins un bouton,
appuyez sur le bouton de coordination
en même temps.
Bouton de coordination qui est là.
De toute manière, oui,
j'ai une led rouge d'allumée.
Donc il va falloir que j'appuie
sur un bouton bleu.
Egalement sur le bouton
de coordination.
Je relâche, je valide.
C'est bon.
Etape 3, ça commence par un six.
Même instruction
qu'à l'étape précédente,
si le nombre affiché à l'écran est impair,
Ce qui est le cas.
Placez l'interrupteur de différenciation
en position haute.
S'il est pair, c'est pas le cas.
Placez-le en position basse.
Sauf si le chiffre des unités est un six,
dans ce cas placez...
Donc ensuite, on a du vert,
on en a deux.
Vert, autant de rouge.
Autant de rouge, coordination,
puisque c'était au PIC-2.
Je relâche, je valide, okay.
PIC-4, même instruction
qu'à l'étape précédente,
considérez qu'il faut retirer 252
au nombre affiché à l'écran.
746.
746 est un nombre pair.
Donc position basse,
sauf si le chiffre des unités est un six,
position intermédiaire.
On revient maintenant à PIC-2.
PIC-2, j'ai un bleu d'allumé.
Un bleu, ça veut dire qu'il faut
que j'allume un vert.
Mais il faut que
j'appuie sur coordination,
Je relâche, je valide.
Erreur.
Je refais.
Ah, il y avait aussi un rouge,
autant pour moi.
Bleu, c'est un vert.
Rouge, c'est un bleu.
Coordination, relâche, valide.
Okay.
C'était avec la manette,
je l'ai pas fait, Fabou.
C'est ça que j'ai oublié.
Coordination, validation.
- Etape 3, terminée.
- C'est bon.
- Résultats exceptionnels.
- Profil type...
- Profil type, grocer V0.
Copie des capacités mentales en cours,
veuillez ne pas retirer le casque.
- Oh putain,
on copie mon cerveau !
- Acquisition des données réussie.
- Sujet deux, deux, un,
un, huit, deux, Fabien Olicard.
- Deux, deux, un, un, huit, deux,
c'est moi.
- Transfert des données dans la pilule.
- ça va dans la pilule.
- Transfert terminé.
- J'ai peur qu'il y ait un truc
qui me pète à la gueule.
- Ouverture du compartiment
de la pilule.
- Il y a un compartiment pilule
qui va s'ouvrir quelque part.
- A bientôt, Monsieur Olicard.
- Merci Monsieur Tesla.
J'ai entendu un "chling-chlouk".
Attends, je crois que c'est ça.
Attendez, fin du test.
Je reviens tout à fait ici.
Oh c'est ça, c'est la pilule
qui est revenue, livre d'or.
Cerebro-coder 3000.
Là dedans, les gars,
il y a tout mon cerveau
plus les cerveaux de ceux
qui sont passés avant moi.
Cher vous, félicitations,
vous êtes arrivé au bout du processus.
Une copie d'une partie
de votre savoir a été synthétisé
dans le comprimé rouge
que vous trouverez ci-joint.
Si mes calculs sont bons,
et ils le sont toujours,
ce comprimé
s'agrège des savoirs,
de l'ensemble des personnes
ayant utilisé la machine jusqu'ici.
Comme il sert aussi
de puce mémoire,
la machine repartira de zéro
si vous le l'ingérez.
Réfléchissez bien, le savoir ultime
et le chemin vers la quête
n'est pas nécessairement
son résultat,
Nikola Tesla, 1888.
Et bien c'est à moi
de laisser mon petit mot.
Et de renvoyer la machine
à un nouveau gros cerveau.
- Tu la bouffes la pilule ou pas ?
- Non, je la laisse.
- Tu la laisses ?
- Bah attends,
ça veut dire qu'il y a qui ?
Il y a quand même Steve Jobs
qui l'a pas pris, je crois.
- Ouais, mais tu peux avoir
le savoir de Steve Jobs.
- Mais non, je supporte très mal
les cols roulés.
Non, je pense qu'il faut relaisser
s'accumuler encore un petit peu le savoir.
C'est pour l'humanité, tu vois ?
Je vais mettre mon petit mot.
Je vais le remettre à l'intérieur,
je vais refermer la machine
et je vais l'envoyer...
Et j'ai une idée.
Merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo,
je sais pas du tout
combien de temps ça dure.
Je voudrais faire
un grand bravo à l'Absterium,
qui a conçu de A à Z
cette boîte pour moi.
Ainsi qu'à fanny et Jérémy,
qui ont en fait,
fait tout le processus créatif,
en tout cas les allers-retours.
Dire le mood que je voulais,
tout ce que je voulais,
parce que je voulais rien savoir.
Je voulais être surpris de tout.
Et c'était juste incroyable à vivre.
En fait, j'ai eu l'impression de faire
un escape game pour moi tout seul,
dans un vrai univers.
Mais avec une boîte...
C'était juste fou,
avec des grands moments.
Bref, je parle moins vite parce que
je suis un peu crevé quand même hein !
Donc n'hésitez pas
à liker cette vidéo,
pensez à vous abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait.
Moi, je m'appelle toujours
Fabien Olicard.
Ici, je vous mets
une vidéo casse-tête,
qui était quand même
beaucoup plus rapide à faire,
et peut-être ça va vous détendre.
Portez vous bien,
prenez soin de vous.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !